the dead speak now you're inferring just
the Palpatine referring to this
Skywalker saga they're still talking at
us they're still justifying plot choices
wanted to talk about a couple things and
then some other movie news as well
before we go into that sincerely do you
want to give our condolences to all
those who were close with James Lipton
from Inside the Actors Studio
I watched countless episodes of inside
the Actor's Studio
so my favorite ones were like Conan
O'Brien actually Johnny Depp's from back
in the day was an amazing one Angelina
Jolie's Harrison Ford there was a time
where you could actually just look up
all these interviews on YouTube and
eventually they had to start taking them
down due to copyright issues and
whatever and I've always thought he was
a fantastic interviewer he was someone
who was truly special and he asked all
these questions that not only got you to
get into the personal life of so many
amazing artists but also you really did
through his question he really did
receive a great study of the craft of
acting but he's also just a wonderful
personality and an such a great sense of
humor I remember watching his
appearances on Conan O'Brien a lot when
he had Late Night with Conan O'Brien
seem to be a great sport about the whole
Will Ferrell parody on SNL which was
hilarious he's someone who's gonna be
really missed I know he did more than
just inside the after studio he actually
an actor
yeah an actor himself and he led that
studio and like it is an actual class
yeah it's really like a gifted
interviewer which isn't always easy to
do and then somebody who could really
open people up yeah so as especially for
acting and what that's all about you
know yeah he was really special to me
rest in peace thoughts and prayers to
his family anyway let's transition to
some Star Wars stuff
Rises Skywalker novel confirms help team
was a clone very very very cool Star
Trek for news also this reloj kiss they
have something I came out about it to
corn in the novel and then now we'll see
what else we got on the agenda today
let's talk about Palpatine officially
being a clone as confirmed by the
novelization of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker she's available on March 17th
so spoilers for the knob they were like
we did of course correct some more throw
this is the novel this is via screen
rats
all the vials were empty of liquid saved
one which was nearly depleted kylo
peered closer he'd seen this apparatus
before too when he'd studied the Clone
Wars as a boy he watched all the seasons
and it was waiting for Disney Plus to
unveil the last season he wasn't able to
catch up before he encountered the
liquid flowing into the living nightmare
before him was fighting a losing battle
to sustain the Emperor's huge red flesh
what could you give me kylo asked
Emperor Palpatine lived after a fashion
and kylo could feel in his very bones
that this clone body sheltered the
Emperor's actual spirit it was an
imperfect result though unable to
contain his immense power that couldn't
last much longer so that must be why he
wanted to suck the life force out her
the body was rejecting it the way how
Isis Skywalker seemed to have been made
was off of course correcting from the
last Jedi and hearing fan base
disagreements here oh man they really
didn't like some things and oh crap we
never really explained how Palpatine is
back I guess that's applied it they
people would ask I didn't think people
would intimate details and backstory so
let's throw it in the book because now
it's canon and they fixed it and this
will drive those book sales up it's
still stupid guys it makes sense
it may it would have been better if you
just threw in a line in the movie and I
think we would have rolled right with I
mean I don't know exactly how clones and
Star Wars work a hundred percent this
doesn't really reveal a ton because it's
actually his spirit it's just a clone
body so it's not really saying much
other than this is a temporary skinsuit
how did two Palpatine's essence survive
well yeah I mean how he did survive from
Return of the Jedi it's explained here
transferred his spirit into a clone and
I guess by having this line here because
one of the criticisms was if he is a
clone why did he choose like this
decaying body they explained here the
it's imperfect vessel yeah it's too evil
it's just sucking up all the life force
and for some reason along the way he
also cloned a bunch of smokes
while he was at it oh yeah it was gonna
jump into that bottom here like this
disappear for the right amount of time
before I come back this is always the
plan according to Colin Trevorrow script
this was always a plan College of aural
of the whole according to the novel here
there's no love in the kiss yes Screen
Rant no lovin the kiss kylo Ren kiss
confirmed to be non romantic here's the
excerpt this is comicbook.com his Ocampo
Montcalm yes yes sorry sorry everyone
his heart was as full as Rey reached for
his face against his cheek and then
wonder of wonders she leaned forward and
kissed him a kiss of gratitude
acknowledgement of their connection
celebration that they'd found each other
at last
but then she drew back concern on her
face she could feel him growing cold Ben
smiled at her he'd given Rey back to the
galaxy
it wouldn't have tone for the darkness
he'd rot but it was what he could do it
was a platonic kiss non romantic at all
she couldn't have just said thank you
she needed to kiss him for their romance
was not properly earned if they had
kissed out of a romantic sense even
though from a third-party perspective it
might look like it was a romantic kiss
but this is more of the kiss Angelina
Jolie might have given her brother back
in the day and a galaxy far making me
back to that memory gratitude kisses
yeah this happened a lot in movies this
just seems to go right back to you know
trying to clear things satisfy the fans
and somehow make the reception of this
movie better so in between all this all
this time from novelization excerpts
being released to the
Raisa Skywalker coming out there was JJ
Abrams getting asked questions about how
he felt towards the criticisms and he
was there to go there alright everyone's
right right now everyone's right
everyone's correct all the theories are
correct everyone's right until the novel
comes out and that's what's correct
depending on what people really don't
like and what they do like I feel like
this a novelization was finished a long
time ago and they held it over just so
that they could address these fan names
which is not an unsmiling
and then on the other spectrum earthing
is one of the things that seems to be
one of the main movie news things coming
out today from the other side of the
galaxy
Star Trek Simon Pegg who did appear in
the force awakens close friends with JJ
Abrams he was speaking of GamesRadar via
dark horizons and here's what he said
about Star Trek the franchise pretty
much why the fourth one's been delayed
the fact is Star Trek movies don't make
Marvel money and make maybe five hundred
million dollars at the most and to make
one now on the scale they've set
themselves is two hundred million
dollars you have to make three times
that to make a profit does he get people
don't realize the Simon Pegg actually
sounds like that he's not British I
don't feel like the last one to the 50th
anniversary the regiment the time
throughout the bone the problem with the
film and we lost momentum
I think lose anti-business year I think
who's an anti Nelson was a huge blow to
our little family our enthusiastic to
another one might have been affected by
that so I don't know I mean yeah I agree
with Simon Pegg on on what they're
talking about here star trek into
darkness didn't even make five hundred
million dollars worldwide Star Trek is
known for more of being like for the
real Trekkie fans it's more of a
philosophical thought-provoking true
spectrum sci-fi that's not about
spectacle and of course when you're
doing your show and then you graduate
into the movies you want to add a little
bit more spectacle into the equation and
it made sense with when they rebooted it
like you could see why they went down
that direction but Star Trek is not Star
Wars I feel like that's what Simon Pegg
was trying to do with bringing Star Trek
beyond to the big screen him co-writing
it and it felt more like an episode out
of Star Trek it seems like paramount
really doesn't know what to do with it
Noah Hawley is expected to helm the the
reboot I mean he had that Lucy movie
come out which wasn't really received
all that well it has great work on
television so I could see why they might
have wanted to bring him to do Star Trek
the same time Simon Pegg is a hundred
percent right and I'm glad he's been
pretty outspoken pretty vocal about like
the issues he's had with the development
because he seems that of anyone on the
cast to have been you know I don't have
any like actual facts to back this up
with other than the fact that it's Simon
Pegg he's known to be a nerd he's known
to be a geek there's a part of him that
just kind of reads to me as feeling
truly not betrayed but disappointed
because he's a real avid fan of it I
think he really did love his experience
especially with the first film that's
true like it was the 50th anniversary
but Star Trek Beyond and they didn't
really push it in the marketing was kind
of weird on it if it felt like it wasn't
all that eventful and yeah that's a
bummer yeah it really is and I mean
since they started the new movie
franchise I've gotten that sense that
there is some kind of spiritual friction
at work I mean for as much as people
especially like the first one I feel
like into darkness is a bit more
divisive but I've always felt like this
franchise was at odds with spectacle
basically because especially even the
stuff that comes in the second movie
with Caan and everything just the
answers are pretty brutish and not as
intellectual as you would hope but I
think that's a great observation is yeah
for somebody like Simon Pegg who grew up
on this stuff that it's also informed
his creativity somebody who's had a hand
in the franchise who's been able to at
least give his two cents on how it ought
to maybe moved forward like I respect
that effort that he's put into it and I
think he's yeah again absolutely right
because these movies arguably ought to
exist on a slightly different scale
aimed at a slightly different piece of
the audience and I think it is a mistake
to try and force them into this mold
that a lot of movies now get forced into
that are like if it ain't Marvel money
it's not worth making that money and I
think that's a pretty near sighted thing
I think we've kind of seen and it's
funny that these two big franchises have
been JJ Abrams central because they both
have trouble with rehash and with not
going very far in terms of their
intellectual inclinations and especially
for Star Trek that is Trek that matters
a lot more but I think JJ were he
false is continuation and conclusion I
think he's great for getting things off
the ground rebooted and my three Star
Trek the 2009 version was awesome and
then the force awakens was a really
successful like walls met with his
criticisms it was a good first step or
relaunching this franchise when he's
like doing these continuations points
where you're like come on dude yes and
it off again yeah and I also think the
point about Anton Yelchin is fare true
as having had three films with him he is
a part of the ensemble and I mean he was
really good in that role so his presence
or lack thereof would certainly be some
kind of hull and then it leaves you to
go well they're gonna recast are they
gonna just put a new character yeah well
I think Star Trek would benefit more
from the mid budget range I don't see
why they don't attempt to do that like
even when I see the trailers for their
shows like Picard and the discovery
yeah discovery like Danny's look so huge
humongo and I've heard good things about
both obviously it's just for the movies
themselves they could take a page out of
what DC's kind of been doing go for
something more in the mid-range and I
think you can do that with Star Trek
like it doesn't need to be this giant
spec like you need like maybe one or two
really cool sequences yeah but you don't
need to pitch it as an action movie yeah
and I think that's the thing too is like
Star Trek has always been at odds with
its budget on TV so I feel like not
having all the money isn't going to
hinder Star Trek all that much and it's
probably gonna create a situation where
the writers got to get more clever like
what happened on the show alright guys
well that's all our galaxy news
apparently Mark Ruffalo wants to rematch
with Thanos that's never gonna happen
more timelines what do you guys think
about Palpatine fishing Mika Ferno as a
clone does it make the movie better does
the love list kiss between kylo and Rey
make the movie better do you want to see
Star Trek for ya leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click the
notification bell and before we wrap
this up when I do some patron name call
outs to some folks who are pledged for
our deleted takes
BTS reward tier we get extra patreon
exclusive lead story as well whole oddly
two moments from like the sketches and
stuff just want to shut these guys out
and those people are Javier Gomez Ruby
Gregory Bullock Ryan Beatty dar Theo de
0 6 6
waters Maria Hammond Everett Baker
Philip J Smith jr. Jennifer's or no
separa Erica Tuesday Josh James no briga
thank you all so much for pledging to
our patreon page go check out us of your
stuff up patreon Durda Jeff Jeff Burton
you